in this video we will discuss the acute
renal failure now this will be the first
video in two part video series on acute
renal failure in part 1 we will discuss
the etiology definitions types and rifle
criteria of ERF in part ii we will
discuss the clinical features diagnosis
and the treatment of ERF so let's first
get the basics of acute renal failure
clear so here are your kidneys and one
of the main function of the kidneys is
to filter the blood and remove the
nitrogenous waste excess of the fluids
and excess of the electrolytes from the
blood and it is the sudden impairment in
the functioning of the kidney and that
too when happens in a short period of
time it leads to increase in the
concentration of these substances and
there can be a lot of problems that can
arise due to excess of the nitrogenous
waste in the body various type of
electrolyte imbalances in the body and
also fluid overload so let us understand
in brief the consequences of acute
impairment of normal kidney function
first coming to the nitrogenous waste
the nitrogenous waste of the body gets
raised which is represented by increased
concentration of blood urea nitrogen as
well as increased serum creatinine
values various type of electrolyte
imbalances can occur in acute renal
failure like the serum sodium
concentration gets decreased serum
potassium gets raised serum calcium gets
decreased the serum phosphate
concentration is raised when serum pH
gets decreased that is the blood becomes
more acidic one simple trick to remember
all of these electrolyte imbalances is
to remember two sets of ions the sodium
potassium calcium and the phosphate and
to remember that the normal serum sodium
is higher as compared to potassium
whereas the normal serum calcium
concentration is higher as compared to
phosphate and these arrows just get
reversed in case of AR F one important
problem in AR F is the fluid in
balance since kidneys are not
functioning properly the body can have
hypervolemia that is excess body water
or hypovolemia that is deficit body
water hypervolemia mainly occurs in oleg
uric and and uric a RF when the kidneys
do not produce enough urine and the
water gets retained in the body and
hypovolemia occurs in advanced ERF when
the kidneys lose their property of
concentration let us understand how we
define acute renal failure and to define
acute renal failure it is important to
remember the normal values of some renal
function tests like normal serum
creatinine concentration which is 0.8 to
1.3 milligrams per deciliter and normal
urine output which is 1 to 3 milliliters
per kilogram per R and when the serum
creatinine concentration Rises more than
3 milligrams in 48 hours or it rises
more than 1.5 times normal value in less
than 7 days the patient is said to be in
acute renal failure it can also be
defined on basis of urine output when
urine output falls less than 0.5
milliliters per kilogram per hour the
kidneys are said to be in a state of
acute renal failure now let us
understand the types and etiology of
acute renal failure so this is a brief
overview of our urinary system the blood
is filtered to the kidneys the kidneys
produce urine which passes through the
ureters into the bladder urine is then
voided out through the urethra another
important structure which lies here is
the prostate so there is there are three
types of acute renal failure the first
is the pre renal ERF second is the renal
AR F and third is post renal AR F coming
to the original type of AR F it mainly
occurs due to inadequate blood perfusion
to the kidneys kidneys is mainly
supplied by the renal artery and in
situations like hypovolemia when there
is total body water deficit the body is
unable to maintain its proper blood
pressure to maintain a normal perfusion
of kidneys this situation mainly arises
in cases of excessive blood loss
diarrhea and vomiting
burns in which there is fluid loss to
the damaged skin and also pancreatitis
in which there is thirdspace loss
pre-delay RF also occurs due to reduced
cardiac output from the heart which are
which leads to decreased blood pressure
and inadequate perfusion of the kidneys
mainly occurs in cases of heart failure
and also septic shock third important
reason of regional a RF is the diseases
of D renal vessels such as the renal
artery stenosis when the lumen of the
renal artery gets blocked the renal type
of a RF occurs due to diseases which are
primarily localized in the kidney most
of you may know that the kidneys are
mainly made of three types of structures
the first important of them is the
glomeruli and the diseases affecting the
glomeruli are called glomerular
nephritis second important type of
structure in the kidney are the vessels
and various type of vasculitis affect
the vessels and damage them and the
third in point structure of the kidney
are the interstitial and diseases like
acute tubular necrosis effect the
interstitial the post renal type of a RF
occurs due to mechanical obstruction in
the flow of urine and this mainly occurs
due to urinary stones which block the
urinary pathway or also prostatic
enlargement in case of benign prostatic
hyperplasia last section of this video
will deal with the rifle criteria of a
RF the word rifle stands for risk injury
failure loss and end-stage renal disease
all of these five words represent a
grade of acute renal failure in
increasing order of severity in the risk
category the serum creatinine arises 1.5
times of baseline whereas the urine
output of the patient Falls less than
0.5 milliliters per kilogram per hour
for at least six hours in the next
category the injury the serum creatinine
rises two times of baseline whereas the
urine output
Falls 2.5 milliliters per kilogram per
our for at least 12 hours in the next
category the serum creatinine Rises 3
times that of normal whereas the urine
output Falls to 0.3 ml per kilogram per
hour for at least 12 24 hours in the LOS
category of rifle criteria if the acute
kidney injury persists for at least 4
weeks it is included in this category
and end-stage renal disease is when
end-stage renal disease persists for 3
months that is when you require a renal
replacement therapy like dialysis for at
least 3 months thank you so much for
watching this video click the link in
the description below for the past
second of this video subscribe to our
channel on YouTube for all the latest
videos and like our page on Facebook for
all the notifications from met
simplified